but while we can't protect every job one
of the most important things we can do
to prevent unemployment is to get as
many people as possible from further
back to their jobs so today we're
introducing a new policy to reward and
incentivize employers who successfully
bring furloughed staff back a new jobs
retention bonus if you're an employer
and you bring someone back who was
furloughed and you continuously employ
them through to January we will pay you
a thousand-pound bonus per employee it
is vital that people aren't returning
just for the sake of it they need to be
doing decent work so for businesses to
get this bonus the employee must be paid
at least 520 pounds on average in each
month from November to January the
equivalent of the lower earnings limit
in national insurance the house should
understand the significance of this
policy we will pay the bonus for all
furloughed employees so if employers
bring back all nine million people who
have been furloughed this would be a
nine billion pound policy to retain
people in work our message to business
is clear if you stand by your workers we
will stand by you